[Music]
so I recently shed my meal prep and also
what I eat in a day you guys loved it
and you requested for an Asian vegan
meal prep so here it is now before I get
started if you haven't yet subscribed to
my youtube channel be sure to do so and
turn on your notification button so that
you would get notified every time I
share a new workout video recipe and
also fitness tips for those of you who
have no idea on what meal prepping is
how or where to start be sure to check
out my video on beginner's guide to meal
prepping it's only 5 really simple steps
but it will get you to eat healthier
this meal prep is great for those of you
who are looking to lose weight if not
you can always increase the portion or
add more meals into your diet so these
are all the ingredients I'll be cooking
with for breakfast I'm making tofu and
veggie rice rolls lunch will be tempered
fried rice and dinner is barley carrot
and sweet corn soup and I'm going to
have red dates with walnuts as my snacks
this entire meal is enough for three
days
so from preparation to cooking and also
storing it will take me roughly about
two hours remember it's all about being
efficient so we're going to start with
the recipe that takes the longest to
cook
followed by simpler meals so I'm going
to start by prepping dinner which is
barley carrot and sweet corn soup what
I've used are half a cup of pure barley
six cups of vegetable stock two Tomatoes
two large onions two medium potatoes two
carrots a head of sweet corn and salt
and pepper to taste
start by prepping and chopping all the
vegetables into thick chunks the next
step is to simply fill up a large pot
with vegetable stock and add in all your
ingredients I'm seasoning mine with a
little bit of salt and pepper now allow
all the ingredients to cook under medium
heat for about 30 minutes until all the
vegetables are tender don't forget to
stir occasionally then set it aside to
let it cool so while waiting for my soup
to cool down let's move on and prep
lunch tempeh fried rice for this young
three cups of cooked brown rice one cup
of temper a half a head of broccoli one
red bell pepper one carrot three stalks
of scallions two tablespoons of olive
oil two tablespoons of soy sauce one
teaspoon of sesame oil and salt and
pepper to taste again start by prepping
all the vegetables and sliced the tempeh
into cubes heat a large pan with one
tablespoon of olive oil over medium-high
heat salted the tempeh until it is
slightly Brown remove and set aside
drizzle the remaining one tablespoon of
oil over medium-high heat then add in
your vegetables broccoli bell pepper and
carrots cook for four to five minutes
until the vegetables are slightly tender
but still crunchy then stir in the rice
and tempeh and continue to cook for a
few more minutes until the rice is
heated through season with a little bit
of soy sauce sesame oil and salt and
pepper then throw in some scallions and
continue to stir until all the
ingredients are well combined remove
from heat and set it aside to cool down
now let's move on and make breakfast
tofu and vegetable rice rolls for this
you'll need 200 grams of firm tofu one
red bell pepper one yellow bell pepper
one carrot one large bunch of mint
leaves one and a half cups of cabbage
two tablespoons of olive oil and in 12
rice paper rolls add for the garlic soy
dipping sauce you'll need two
tablespoons of soy sauce half a
tablespoon of rice vinegar 2 teaspoons
of sesame oil and one teaspoon of minced
garlic
let's start by Finley slicing all the
vegetables and sliced the tofu into long
strips over medium-high heat cook the
tofu on each side for about three to
five minutes or until golden brown
set aside next we want to prep the
dipping sauce so in a small bowl combine
all the ingredients together and mix
well now let's assemble the rice rolls
to soften the rice paper wraps in a
large plate add in a little bit of warm
water and dip the rice
Rep very quickly for 10 to 15 seconds
and spread it carefully onto a damp
cloth then arrange all the colorful
vegetables and tofu gently roll the rice
paper wrap and voila there you have it
so I'm making child rose enough for
three days if you want to you can always
make more finally I'm going to prep a
really simple and quick snack
rate date stuffed with walnuts this is a
very popular Chinese snack it is sweet
satisfying and extremely healthy so
combined with walnuts this snack is high
in antioxidants and also healthy fats
simply slice the red date to create a
small pocket and remove the seed then
insert half a walnut into the red date
then now that all the meals have cooked
down it is time to store them into
airtight containers I'm going to scoop
the soup into three equal portions then
place for rice rolls into each container
as for lunch
I'm packing fried rice with more
vegetables on the side always remember
that you can consume vegetables in
abundance and finally the red dates and
walnuts as my snacks so this is my meal
prep for three days the total calories
for all the meals are only 1200 calories
remember this does not include my
protein shake which I will have after a
workout session or a cup of coffee or a
small dessert just to enjoy so I will
give myself another 3 to 400 calorie
allowance use this as your guideline
remember your calorie intake will differ
based on your fitness goals and also
your body composition do try this meal
prep out and let me know what recipes do
you want more up remember you have to
also stay active ok so check out my
workout videos
and don't forget to subscribe to my
youtube channel and turn on your
notification button and be sure to snap
pictures and tag me all the best